depuis la crise sanitaire les clients se
font rares dans cet hôtel de
marly-le-roi pour relancer son activité
le gérant intégré l'opération week end
zen en vallée de seine à package lancé
par la chambre de commerce et de
l'industrie des yvelines dans ce
dispositif la deuxième chambre est
proposée à 50 % et les petits déjeuners
sont gratuits pour les moins de 12 ans
on a besoin actuellement
bien sûr que ça peut être une bouffée
d'oxygène pour notre tel pour pouvoir
approcher d'autres clients et bien sûr
ce qui nous permettra de nous faire
connaître si et c'est une opération qui
commence à prendre de l'ampleur et je
pense que on aura on aura des
répercussions sur les relais sur les
semaines à venir quoi le package
comprend également une visite dans un
lieu touristique à proximité de l'hôtel
ici à marly-le-roi ce le musée domaine
royal de marly qui a été retenue par la
cci
l'objectif est évidemment de toucher un
public qui ne serait peut-être pas venu
spontanément au musée mais là forcément
et bien le
l'entrée du musée étant inclus dans le
package ça va toucher un public qui
serait peut-être venu pour le côté
nature que propose la ville de marly le
roi mais pas nécessairement sur le col
de volet culturel au total cet hôtel
situé entre bougival et rolleboise
participent à ce dispositif destiné à
attirer une clientèle francilienne
c'est une opération qui fait partie
d'une opération plus global qui
s'appelle spot qui consiste à valoriser
la vallée de la seine val et valoriser
la partie touristique de la vallée de la
seine c'est à dire en collaboration et
toutes les offices du tourisme de
pouvoir
aider tout ce qui est musée hôtel
restaurant de la vallée de la seine à
être valorisés
le package se poursuivra jusqu'à la fin
de l'été d'autres complexes hôteliers
pour est intégrée l'opération dans les
prochaines semaines